[Musik]
[Applaus]
mutter leistung 260 ps besatzung maximal
neun mann gesamtmasse 13 5 tonnen
höchstgeschwindigkeit 100 km/h
einsatzgebiete friedenssichernde und
erhalten der auslandseinsätze
wir beide etwas gemeinsam wir kommen
beide aus österreich und haben uns
international einen namen gemacht in der
stadt von kraft und das ist aber durch
bad bank der vom österreichischen
bundesheer
er ist ein mannschaftstransporter er
seinen insassen schützt vor beschuss von
rolf eierwürfen geliebte außerdem ist er
enorm wendig und schnell und positiv ein
bis zwei meter sein problem
[Musik]
[Applaus]
panzer seien im vergleich zu ketten
waren zu viel leisten werden natürlich
viel später wahrgenommen
zudem hinterlassen sie viel weniger
schäden auf den straßen weil die räder
den untergrund weniger belasten
österreich ist der radpanzer bandur beim
jägerbataillon 19 und hier in straße in
jeder partie auf 17 stationiert
[Musik]